okay folks right according to
the power of the internet it is
apparently now nine o'clock so um okay
uh good morning
uh see responsive that's what we want in
an architecture
um so uh you may be aware that Britain's
been going through some social upheaval
in recent years this is some of our
latest architecture
um
and
so
what I want to talk about is refactoring
I want to talk about the fact that it's
not just a shortcut key many people
think of it in those terms ever since it
got integrated into Ides
but refactoring has a longer history and
it also has a different story a story
that is rooted in design and design
thinking
so
the reason this is here is not merely
social commentary
and political satire
it is the observation that many of us
deal with Legacy code
in fact most you spend most of your time
programming in the past
okay you think you're on the you think
you're in technology and therefore
everybody in your family thinks not only
can you fix their computer
but you're on the Leading Edge
but you spend most of your time
programming in the past
the languages you use
they were either developed last century
or at the beginning of this Century
statistically speaking there are a few
of you who are using languages that were
actually invented in the last decade but
you're in a relative minority most of
what you are doing is in the past you
sit down you write a piece of code it is
very unlikely that that code remains in
the present most of your code is written
against something that was written
yesterday last week last month last year
you are programming in the past
in an eight-hour day you spend seven to
seven and a half hours working in the
past dealing with the consequences of
what was there
so for an industry that is focused on
the future we're really pretty crap at
it
so surely refactoring solved these
problems that's what I want to deal with
um but why is it we end up with stuff
like this Legacy systems here we have a
legacy system apparently it's a rather
large astronomical clock we don't know
who built it we don't know why they
built it but twice a year it works
now sometimes it's not just that
sometimes there's another side to
develop us
oh we love complexity
we can look at somebody says here I have
a simple requirement and it seems that
many developers look at the simple
requirement and go
you know what I can make that harder
I just heard I just heard wait a minute
the last five minutes yes there's a new
JavaScript framework let's use that
okay
so we have an innate
technical joy and the point is I'm not
saying that's a bad thing it's actually
what got many of us involved or
interested in software but we need to
recognize that every good thing has
another side to it the very fact that
you enjoy
kind of puzzle solving expressing
Solutions working with these things and
that Joy of getting something working
sometimes has this side effect that you
do exactly that when it's not necessary
now many people talk about this in terms
of technical debt technical debt is a
widely misunderstood metaphor a lot of
people use technical debt just to mean
bad the whole point is let me just
remind you the debt metaphor is supposed
to tell you that you can have debt and
it can be good or bad technical debt is
not a bad thing when I hear people say
oh we have technical debt okay so what I
have debt as well
the question is not do you have it is do
you manage it
the thing I want to hear from people is
not we have lots of technical debt it's
it's whether or not they have managed or
unmanaged technical debt that's the
extra word that's really important if
you have managed technical debt that is
not a problem well done you're doing the
right thing
that's the whole point of debt to get an
advantage through occurring a debt that
you can then responsibly repay
however most people have a really bad
experience with debt both in code and in
the real world so they short they
short-circuit it to mean bad but that's
not the full metaphor and if you ever
have a dashboard that tells you your
debt value
in krona euros dollars or whatever
I won't choose pounds because pounds are
really not worth very much these days
but I'm really glad my expenses are
being paid in Corona I'm winning you
know in the months since I bought my
flights I am actually earning a profit
um
if you have that on your dashboard
that's bad science that's false numbers
you cannot turn technical debt into a
numerical currency value if you're not
sure why that's a separate talk and I'm
happy to have it as a conversation but
it's actually if you think no no but we
have it no it's against the laws of
physics and Mathematics so if you think
you have it you don't
but it is a useful thing but I don't
want to talk about the debt side of
things I want to talk about how he got
there this is a term I started using
recently as in last week
I found myself talking to a client and I
suddenly realized we keep focusing on a
consequence but not the cause technical
debt is not a cause of technical debt
of itself there are many things one RNA
desire for complexity
one the Blind Eye that we turn to things
that's called neglect
okay we we have parallel instead of
looking to economics we need to look at
Psychology physical neglect emotional
neglect things like that technical
neglect is the problem that we suffer in
code bases not technical debt
technical debt is the effect what is the
cause technical neglect so
this leads us to refactoring and
yeah you've got to quote either XKCD or
commit strip so today I'm doing commit
strip if you've not come across commit
strip that's your homework
okay a couple of guys in Belgium do this
it's fantastic
um so we'll refactor the manager on the
left we'll be factoring the code improve
the loading time developer on the right
not really
well would improve security then no so
is it for a browser compatibility
absolutely not
so tell me why is it always the same old
story with you guys wanting to refactor
everything I need to know
because as devs we know if we know we've
left Mexico we can't stop thinking about
it when we wake up in the morning at
lunchtime in the evening when we go home
and when we're trying to go to sleep it
haunts us
a lot of developers are very
conscientious it's just like oh that
haunts me like I know it could be better
I know there's something else I could do
and why is that because normally what
we're doing when we're writing code is
we're expressing an idea ideas are not
stationary your understanding of ideas
changes with time and experience it
could change 10 minutes after you wrote
a piece of code it could change 10 days
after a piece of code after somebody
raised a question or you mentored
somebody and you explained to them and
you suddenly go well now my explanation
makes this code look really stupid
because there's a much easier way of
doing it but don't blame yourself
because you couldn't have known you're
always in a learning process we're
always working with incomplete knowledge
so therefore the whole point is that
software is soft
okay we keep forgetting that you're
supposed to be able to change it it's
supposed to keep up with your current
thinking it's supposed to be a
reflection of here's what we understand
collectively as a team the problem is
most of what we understand appears to be
what we understood five years ago and we
are fighting the past
so
there are lots of definitions of
architecture so I'm going to get a bit
poetic architecture has inhabited
sculpture
I think this is a lovely way of looking
at architectures generally but I think
it also applies to our code bases we
often forget that when we talk about
software architecture we are often
talking about the Technologies we're
talking about the physical arrangement
that's the natural
parallel for architecture but we forget
in software that the point of
Architecture is to live and work inside
it buildings are not there merely to be
structures they are structures for
people
software architecture is for developers
to live inside and you can ask yourself
what is that experience like does it
feel Pleasant
or do you feel like you're in a horror
movie do you feel that instead you know
some people go yeah my the code base is
really nice it's very habitable you know
it's nicely lit there's some beautiful
tests over there I love the elegant code
over here my packages are all arranged
like so and it's just like yeah I feel I
can get a coffee anywhere and just relax
with the code and make changes I feel
comfortable and confident
on the other hand you might be in a
horror scenario yeah you kind of go in
it's dark and dimly lit there's some
planking somewhere and some there's
something dripping somewhere and it
sounds like a child scream in the
distance and I know that at least three
developers have gone in and not come out
yet
we're on a recruitment Drive
so that's it it's inhabited culture what
is it like to live in the code that
experience of being there
so where's refactoring fit in now this
is a quote I've heard attributed to many
people
um Michelangelo gets credited a lot with
this one but it's actually much more
recent George Pentecost there is a
beautiful angel in that block of Marvel
I'm going to find it all I have to do is
knock off the outside pieces of marble
and be very careful not to Chisel into
the angel with my chisel
this is to some extent the limits of
refactoring in the real world or
creating a design in the real world but
guess what in software software is much
softer we can chisel into the angel and
then put the pieces back and it doesn't
cost us anything in software we have
time travel
which is kind of cool okay oh I'll undo
that I will revert to a previous version
next time you are talking to your
members of your family who want you to
fix their computer say no I'm a time
traveler that is what I do for a living
I travel in Virtual spaces I travel
through space and time you want me to
fix your computer that's a hardware
problem
that's the stuff of Mortals yeah okay so
this is a classic book published in 99
this is before refactoring tools became
widely available so what's the book
about it Martin goes through
he goes through a series of practices
and he shows you the intermediate steps
that you need to take to change one
thing from another whether you are doing
a rename an extract method extract class
whether you are adding parameters
removing parameters whatever you're
doing he makes sure that you understand
the steps involved if you are doing this
manually
a lot of people forget that that's in
there and it's a really important idea
because he's trying to show you that
refactoring is about a gradual change
automated refactoring speeds that up but
it does it in those steps
but there's also something else here
this is the the time this book came out
this was not an accepted practice the
terminology of refracting was relatively
new
you know Bill Opdyke was one of the
people responsible for actually
legitimizing it this is also in the wave
of extreme programming so this is before
the term agile was adopted these ideas
are coming out and actually saying this
is a first class idea but most
importantly I want to refer you to the
subtitle
improving the design of existing code
this is a design practice
and that's a really important Point
Martin was not saying here's ways of
tidying up your code here's ways of
managing technical debt he was talking
about the idea of improving the design
it's a design it's a design practice
he also offered a definition of what is
refactoring
it is a change made to the internal
structure of software to make it easy to
understand and cheaper to modify without
changing its observable Behavior
now an important point about this is
that it is based on making things easy
to understand it doesn't mean that what
was there was wrong it just means that
our understanding has improved and our
understanding has improved for a number
of reasons either yeah it was really bad
or it was really good but the world has
moved on and now it looks kind of out of
place it solved a problem that we had
but you know that that 5K switch
statement didn't feel too bad but now
with 25 cases I'm beginning to think I
might have taken a wrong turn somewhere
it doesn't mean that the five cases was
bad it just means that 25 is no longer
good and that's a point we're allowed to
retake that decision now if this were
physical and logistical I'd have to move
stuff I'd have to move rocks or you know
stop not in software we don't have a
logistics
there are a few laws of physics we have
to respect but most of them
we're Time Travelers okay
and actually the interesting thing about
this is that the second edition this is
exactly the same definition it has not
changed without changing there's a
certain irony about that so the text of
this is identical and second edition
which came out in 2019.
um and this one
also still tells you the manual steps
that you want to take even though this
lives in a world in which Ides have made
refactoring normal the point is that
Martin is still trying to get you to
think that's a really important thing
going on here now I mentioned Bill
Opdyke
and I want you to kind of notice this so
refactoring object oriented Frameworks
this is his PhD it was submitted in the
early 90s
um his work was from the late 80s to the
early 90s this is refactoring in its
original form his PhD supervisor is
Ralph Johnson
okay who is better known for the gang of
four patents gamma gamma Helm Johnson
for cedis that's that Johnson
and these guys Ralph and colleagues did
a lot a lot of work on refactorings
where a lot of this came from and so for
a lot of people when they think about
the story of refactoring they think okay
that's available in tools that I use
but if you know a bit more history
you'll go but refraction kind of grew up
in the Java space that's where it became
the first class thing that's where Ides
started actually saying this is normal
this is not an extra this is not an
add-on this is not a plug-in this is
integrated
but many people there go actually it
started in the small talk Community
that's Ralph Johnson stuff actually it
didn't this is in C plus plus the
original language under which most of
the research for refracting was done in
the late 80s early 90s with C plus plus
ironically the language that is perhaps
received the least love in this
department uh since
Bill update says the refactorings are
defined to be Behavior preserving that
kind of that that phrase again Behavior
preserving so what do we mean by that
so let's talk about possibly the most
over-specified abstract data type in the
history of computing the stack
okay I'm gonna I'm just going to focus
on four operations stack is a vertical
concept Stacks don't have length a stack
is a vertical concept so depending on
your perspective they either have depth
or they have height I tend to think of a
push down stack therefore it and
physically most Stacks it's just like
yeah it has a depth you go from the top
downwards the language of top tells us
that we're looking at something there
you can push things onto it and you can
pop things off now I'm going to focus on
this just being a strict pop in other
words it doesn't return a value as a
result it just reduces the top uh it
just drops okay so we're going to keep
it really simple
um
my language of choice today is going to
be
JavaScript
for some reason
maybe I didn't have enough coffee first
thing
um but there's an interesting thing here
is this is a really what I'm going to do
is I'm just going to Simply use a very
pure object form JavaScript has many
different object models you can use a
conventional class keyword which was
added in
ecmascript 6 2015 or you can use kind of
classic prototyping model or you can use
the purest object model that it supports
which is that of a closure basically I'm
going to return effectively a record a
Cartesian product of
um operations in other words I'm going
to offer you here's a set of operations
that's that's a pure object it doesn't
have a type it's it's it just is a set
of operations and I'm going to make my
data private by it being local this is
the whole idea of block structured
programming the idea that blocks are a
unit of encapsulation you don't need a
private keyword it's truly truly private
because it's inside a block and that
block outlives the life of the function
from which it comes
and then I'm going to bind my operations
to lambdas which are bound to this
private scope
and I'm going to implement it in terms
of the built-in array which does in fact
conveniently enough have push and pop
operations but I'm not but I'm making
mine a pure object model it's purely
method based and I'm going to wrap this
okay so I've got an implementation it's
all one-liners that's nice so okay
that's great we've just learned about
object orientation where's the
refactoring well what about this
what I've done is I've just turned the
underlying representation back to front
I've now decided that I'm going to use
element zero as the top instead of the
last element length minus one I have
just changed the representation and it
will break no code because it is a
refactoring I have preserved the
behavior from an external for an
external Observer this is identical well
is it well yes we need to distinguish
the term behavior and that's something
that the problem is the word Behavior
has too many meanings
and the way that
Martin and Bill were using it was to
imply just semantic Behavior but we need
to distinguish different kinds of
behavior and it's also worth
distinguishing the kinds of change that
we make to code
because this is also another thing when
we find people using the term
refactoring sometimes it gets It suffers
semantic diffusion I've certainly
encountered people who will sit there
and anything they're doing is
refactoring oh what are you doing I'm
refactoring oh so what's the refactoring
it's a bug fix well that's not a
refactoring the whole point of a bug fix
is to change the observable Behavior
it's broken now it's not that's the
purpose okay so they use refactoring as
a more fancy word for the word change I
am changing my code doesn't sound very
technical if you say refactoring whoa
that's great okay so I'm going to give
you a simple kind of right hand rule I'm
going to have to hold my left hand here
no no amazing exchange you see I reverse
the representation fantastic so I've got
a right hand rule here and it's not
these are not perfectly orthogonal these
genuinely aren't perfect orthogonal and
neither of these
uh I want to focus on three different
qualities that you might see in a piece
of code it's functional qualities it's
to it's operational quality is its
developmental qualities the functional
qualities are the semantics that's the
thing we normally talk about in unit
tests it's the how did the values
change how the values transform what
events were raised
okay there's no question of timing and
resources operational is how did it run
did it run fast did it run slow
did it use more or less memory
that stack changes in the way that it
uses things there's a time difference
because we are using a different end and
therefore we are adding things if we are
appending
versus pre-pending there is a different
performance linear versus constant
amortized constant time so there is a
difference in that that does not show up
in the unit test there is an operational
change many refactorings will actually
result in minor or major changes in
performance characteristics either for
the better or for the worse or they stay
the same
developmental qualities of the code is
well how good is it how habitable is it
how easy to change is it so whenever
you're making changes if you think of
these three axes it clarifies things
rather just I'm changing code is what is
my goal here so
um when I had a feature what is my goal
in adding a feature well it's to add
more functionality I am trying to take
that axis and do more of it we had this
much functionality now I'm going to have
this much functionality after my change
what happens to the operational
developmental axis well
maybe they stay the same
maybe things get better maybe things get
worse that's not I mean we'd always like
things to get better but the goal of
feature Edition that's not their goal
bug fixing kind of looks the same except
it works from a different perspective
with bug fixing what you're doing is you
are taking a deficit in functionality
okay instead of we have this much
functionality and now you're going to
have this what is a bug we promised you
this much functionality but you've got
this a bug is a shortfall it's a deficit
if you want debt that's a debt you have
a feature debt that's what a bug is we
promise you this you can't have it oh
you can do this except that crashes
everything oh you can do this except it
munges your data in bad ways oh okay
that's a that's not what we want so
therefore we make up for it but now we
get to the interesting stuff what about
optimization
optimization is a functionality
preserving transformation by the way
that phrase functionality preserving
transformation drop that into
conversation casually it sounds good
okay
but that's what it is you are preserving
the semantics the goal of optimization
is to improve something on the
operational axis and
to maintain one of the other axes the
performance the semantics fixed because
there's no virtue in saying hey look it
runs 10 times faster yeah but it crashes
every single time but damn it's a fast
crash
that's not a virtue here okay
the idea is you don't want to break
things so therefore you keep one thing
fixed whilst you improve the other the
wild card is what happens to the
operational developmental quality
sometimes an optimization
will not necessarily add any complexity
to the code sometimes it will add
complexity to the code
a piece of code that uses caching is
more complex than a piece of code that
is not therefore it is developmentally
lower quality from the perception of the
user if there's more cognitive load that
I have to deal with that's not
necessarily A Bad Thing but we have to
understand that's a payment
on the other hand Sometimes some of the
greatest performance improvements come
through deleting code and simplifying
things it's just like whoa wait a minute
what's going on here in fact I mentioned
caching
one of my clients had four levels of
caching they'd accumulated in a legacy
code base over time every time they
migrated platforms and stuff like that
it's just like okay oh that went faster
but I think we can make it go even
faster they went faster because they
moved to a different platform
the problem is optimizations are often
based on a very delicate set of
assumptions and any of those change then
your optimization disappears it turns
out that rather than recheck the
validity of the optimizations they just
accumulated them when you deleted all of
the caching it ran significantly faster
yeah it turns out that none of it was an
optimization and none of it was
necessary anymore
but you still want the same semantic
Behavior it's the time that changes
that's part of that axis and then we hit
refactoring
which is another functionality
preserving transformation
which is basically my goal here is to
improve something about the
developmental quality
improve the habitability of the code
repay some technical debt
the act of refactoring is the opposite
of technical neglect it's it's actually
technical care
what happens to the performance
characteristics often it Remains the
Same but it may get a little bit worse
it may get a little bit better but
that's not the goal
so Martin also offers a definition of
refactor as a verb what does it mean to
do it
well it means to restructure software by
applying a refactoring
and interestingly enough more
importantly Bill optike's thesis was on
automated refactoring so this is over 30
years ago
now
this is a book that um I edited uh 2009
came out 2010
um
kind of in fact I recognize their own
actually a few speakers
who are representative in fact I'd just
say Norwegians are disproportionately
represented in this book
um but
one of the
um guidelines from Dan tur horse North
was code in the language of the domain
and actually the example that he uses
here
um is oh it's crowdsourced but it's also
an Open Source book it's available on
get books
um
uh
the example that Dan uses is actually a
really good example of a number of
things
um good abstraction but also refactoring
if we look at this
what we are confronted by is something
where all of the elements are well named
we don't need to do a rename
because
there's nothing wrong with the
terminology portfolio IDs by Trader ID
this is perfectly sensible
the get and contains key that comes from
the Java library on a map get ID get ID
Trader portfolio these are all good
names there's no names that I need to
change the only abbreviation there is
actually a real world abbreviation ID is
a real world abbreviation not a
programmatic abbreviation
and yet it's not clear what's going on
here
what we are missing actually is a name
you know we're naming an implied idea
it's not a rename it's giving a name
sometimes there's a missing name what is
this called it doesn't want to comment
it wants to be abstracted the semantic
level at which we're working is can this
Trader view this portfolio this is to do
with governance this is to do with
whether or not somebody is allowed to
see something or not because perhaps
they are doing Insider dealing if they
can see it and that's a bad thing
so what we've got here is this classic
extract method which you can do manually
or you can do it automated
so last year I kind of posted this
um one of the great things about
languages is modern ID support is thanks
to refactoring tools Legacy code is the
thing of the past
along with all the languages developers
never have to experience long methods
rounding classes poor identifier names
with complex logic or any of these
things
isn't it great that we live in an age
where we don't have to tolerate
these kinds of issue because we have
tools that address them
I mean you just sit there going like you
know particularly the older ones of you
you just say I'm so relieved I don't
have to deal with poorly named code
anymore
it's such a great comfort to me that I
don't open this up and find methods that
are longer than one screen
I live in an age of joy and for those of
you who and have no idea what it was
like before you're going oh I'm so glad
I don't live in the Dark Ages
the only dark thing about my code is
dark mode
foreign
by this
that is what refactoring meant as we
started getting tools that did this I
remember doing a talk for the Java User
Group
yavabin here in Oslo in 2003 at the
University and somebody came up to me
and he said all these things you're
talking about Kevin we don't need to
worry about them anymore because we have
refactoring tools and I kind of like
I kind of smiled at yeah the great thing
you know even then I was older than this
guy it's just
so sweet you're so young
you know had I had the benefit of of
foresight and Game of Thrones I would
have said Oh My Sweet Summer child
that's not how this works
yeah some people miss the fact that I
was joking in this original tweet and
made comments but Kevin we do have this
and that's the point
why do we have this when we have the
tools that solve the problem
most things that people talk about in
terms of unmanaged technical debt or
technical neglect are solved problems
most people experience and complain
about and are experiencing on a
day-to-day basis basis
problems that have been solved it's not
like we don't know how to do this when I
entered the industry
I was having to deal with a Fortran
Legacy code base
we did not have any of the language or
insights or any of this thing I do not
want to go back to that I don't want to
live in that past and yet now I do
we produce a lot more code than we used
to so what happened it turns out
it tools were never the problem that's
why I think it's so important that
refactoring is not about your idea if
your ID doesn't have refactoring that
doesn't stop you that was never the
problem automation lowers the barrier to
entry but if you're not prepared to take
it as an option it turns out it's this
it's not the tools it's our ability to
understand and feel empowered to do it
that's the obstacle and that's not
toolable
so I just started you know this I like
kicked off this thread last year
because I just thought actually yeah
seriously
um refraction questions what family of
refractors do you find you use most
whether it's automated or not
you probably already in your head have
an answer to this you can probably think
of the top one two maybe three
but also one of the ones that you're
aware of that you think people don't use
enough what the factors do you feel are
most overlooked or underutilized or it's
by you or others
so
the one you know extract method there
was no surprise
importantly it's not the extract family
it's the extract method okay that one is
a really common one perhaps the most
common one is rename
okay to the point that sometimes I find
people doing a rename refactoring on
something that only has one occurrence
like you know like a test name you don't
need to refactor that the whole point of
a refactoring tool is it updates all
references to things so in other words
it's become so ingrained in people's
fingers they don't even they think of it
as just a even when they could just
rename it there they do a rename
refactoring
but of course there are limits to this
you can't rename everything I don't want
to give you the impression that you can
just change everything software does
have boundaries of hardness
that has publication boundaries
observation from Josh block public apis
like diamonds are forever once you push
something out to people that you don't
influence or control oh good luck with
changing that
and that again let's go back to 2003
I was dealing with a team in Germany
and one of their guys again had fallen
in love with the refactoring tools
that's great and he says yeah we're
getting some real friction and real
pushback from that team over there who
are writing automated test tools for the
uh for our code systems level
um and they don't like the fact that we
refactor and I said and yeah they're
they're real luddites they're holding us
back and I said well what's the problem
well you know I'll just refactor and
I'll change the name of something on
interface or I'll I'll delete an
interface and stuff like that and said
so basically what you're doing is you're
interrupting their workflow
why should they be pleased with that the
point is that there is an inside and an
outside to things there is a boundary
you can't ease it once you go across a
boundary it's no longer a question of
tooling and software engineering it's
social engineering you are pissing that
team off because they walk in and it's
just like oh I've now got things to fix
whereas I didn't you're creating work
for other people so I said you know you
need to understand what the boundaries
are
and you basically want a soft centered
Suite
okay whatever your boundaries component
layer whatever uh class you know it's
Turtles all the way down it's a very
fractal thing software it's tougher on
the outside and more stable than it is
on the inside this is really important
otherwise you end up with you know we
can see the problem you can't just
refactor stuff my favorite example is is
clonable
Okay so clonable
you probably recognize this as an
interface or if you don't recognize
clonable that's that's in the jvm if
you're in the.net space icloneable
you developer I hate that I prefix we'll
come back to that later
I understand people use it but it is one
of the dumbest things ever
um I will demonstrate its dumbness and
how it's anti-software Engineering in a
moment but you're in you're entitled to
use it you know it's your choice you
just know you're doing something wrong
um
the point there is this one jumped the
gene pool it went from
and you know lots of languages now have
this but here's the really interesting
thing
I'm sure you okay so this is Norway and
most of you are Norwegians all learning
Norwegian
and you get a new spelling convention I
don't know every five years which
confuses the hell out of people but
every time a Dane comes to Norway they
go oh thank goodness spelling actually
works
okay it's kind of vaguely fanatic even
as even as an English speaker I can kind
of look at some Norwegian and go yeah I
can kind of understand that I don't have
to figure out too much it looks vaguely
phonetic
English
no not so much
but in as much and sometimes people say
English doesn't have a logical system of
spelling
I'm really interested in language I have
bad news for you
it's the problem is not that English
doesn't have a logical system of
spelling is that English has about half
a dozen logical systems of spelling
simultaneously all in the same language
in the same word sometimes
I believe that's called competitive
spirit
but in as much as there is a correct
spelling of clonable it doesn't have
that first e
what happens if I wanted to refactor
that
what happens if I'm Microsoft and I go
yeah you know what let's just refactor
that what happens if I'm Oracle I want
to refactor that
then you just hear the sounds of systems
breaking all around the world
that's what publication means that's not
your interface anymore okay you've given
up control of it
however I'd just like to point out
that with great power comes great
responsibility here is the Wiktionary
entry on clonable Alternative forms
especially in Computing contexts well
done us we have changed the spelling of
a word through repeated misspelling
repetition legitimizes repetition
legitimizes repetition legitimizes it
makes it real
but what we learned from this is a
simple guidance that not all things are
created equal we misunderstand the
boundaries that what we want to do is we
want to encourage the softness that as
much as possible
and this is not new advice this is last
century advice don't publish interfaces
prematurely
modify your code ownership policies to
smooth refactoring there is a philosophy
here it's a design philosophy
what this also means goes against what
some people think of as being a practice
make code AS open to modification as
possible Don't Close Your code
modification don't make your code
extensible
these are bad practices these are not
good if you are interested in Agile
development and keeping software soft
you make your code as much of your code
AS modified as possible you eliminate
the possibility of extension that is not
necessary and when you discover it is
necessary you will have the knowledge to
do it effectively rather than creating a
debt
we can call this the closed open
principle
so
what about the ones that people neglect
extract class really not very popular
which is why we end up with large
classes we're a lot happier to extract a
method but something about a class
pushes it into a bound and pushes it
across a boundaries like it's like a
surface tension issue it's really or an
escape velocity it's just like oh I'm
not going to pull that into another
class because that probably means I put
it in another file and that's another
different thing in the version control
system and I'll have to oh now I'm not
going to create a new file for that
that's that's that's that's too much
there's too much of a an activation
energy to get to that level I'll just
keep it here you know nobody will notice
because the class is already 10 000
lines long nobody's going to notice
another few lines
so
inlining the opposite of extraction
sometimes we want to do things that are
the opposite simplify by actually
removing an abstraction
replacing things deleting things oh
we're really bad at that
as I noted quite a while back now we
keep talking about incremental
development we don't talk enough about
decremental development there is a real
skill in getting rid of the things that
you don't want
do we need this no is there a simple way
of doing it yes is any other piece of
code calling no I can't get rid of it
that's that code is dead you don't want
to come back to life when you're not
expecting it zombie code is bad it has
cost the world billions of dollars
so there is a kind of philosophy that
people normally think of in the context
language that we get from lean
um Kaizen or let's give them that it's
Japanese I will show you the uh hiragana
um
can I say in Japanese basically means
just Improvement but in a business
context
it has a very specific meaning the idea
of continuous Improvement the idea of
like we're always doing it's gradual
it's gradual this is kind of like the
everyday
you brush your teeth you have a shower
type thing you don't save it up till the
end of the month
okay you know this is the way a lot of
teams do refactoring that's okay uh you
know I'm going to save time by not
brushing my teeth and having a shower
today I will save it all up to the end
of the month and then I will spend
the last Sunday of the month just just
brushing my teeth and having showers and
then I will see all those people who've
been avoiding me for the last few weeks
which has been like honestly a lot
easier with working from home
um but the point there is that this is
the gradual stuff
it's it's the prevention of Decay or
it's the gradual Improvement it's the we
always do one good thing
okay just clean things up a little bit
and it's this Progressive stable
intermediate form that we're interesting
each step that we go through is a good
step when you've refactored what you've
got may not be perfect but it was better
than what you had before it's moving in
a direction you may not be at your
destination yet so very simple example
um let's let's play around with words by
quinary coded decimal
um this is a fun word
um it's a counting system of
representing numbers based on counting
in fives I have no idea where that came
from
with an additional indicator to show
whether the count is in the first or the
second five okay so in other words we
break it down into tens but then we have
two groups of five and we can either be
counting one to five six to ten or zero
to four five to nine and there are a
number of systems that use this classic
Abacus systems not the kinds you give to
your kids because that really messes
with them this kind of thing okay I
remember as a kid seeing one of these
and going like this is really stupid it
only goes up to seven
um
it's like looking at a bike and going
like okay there's three gears there and
there's five gears there my bike has
eight gears no that's not how it works
by quinary this is still used in some
parts of the world very effective but
it's a bike Winery system okay you have
an upper register for lower or upper
five and then you have your five very
effective
um it was actually used on early
computers
before we discovered the joy of just
like sort it just do it in binary but we
faked up a decimal system and here we
have the Colossus with human computers
um feeding feeding the machine
um
but perhaps one of the classic number
systems a non-positional counting system
is the Roman numeral system
it's based on fives you probably never
really thought about it like that you
just thought about it as a kind of a
bunch of letters you know that um
made you live it
um but you know remembering the various
letters and this gives us a nice really
simple Carter so the kind of standard
Carter is okay I'm going to take a
number I'm going to take an integer and
I'm going to convert it into Roman
numerals I'm going to convert it into
string form sure fine go ahead and if
you tackle this in a kind of enterprisey
way you'll end up with code like this
if you are being paid by the line of
code this is an absolutely fantastic way
of doing it
it is needlessly imperative it's all
about State change it's a lot of
repetition
and I would generally say this is I mean
I'm not saying there's anything wrong
with doing this as your first cut
Solution that's the whole point it's if
this is the way that you're programming
in it go for it there is nothing wrong
with doing that remember your software
is soft
okay you're not this is not you're not
committing anything to anybody you're
not making a promise this is how it's
going to be you're just getting your
thoughts out on paper there's nothing
wrong with writing this there is a
problem with checking it in though and
saying yep I'm done
there is a problem with putting in a
book
like this this is the thing I was
absolutely fascinated by a couple so I
like that here I like looking into the
history of programming I think we
software development doesn't have a very
long history but it does have a history
and you know history is a vast early
warning system
of all the mistakes we're going to make
again
and there is the classic quote you know
those who those who do not know history
are destined to repeat it there was also
the counter quote that those who do know
history are destined to watch it being
repeated
and Pascal was often held up as the
language to learn it's a good teaching
language I say I I I'm going to go
against that
I said originally I did Fortran when I
saw Pascal I thought this is fantastic
now I have a bit more experience Pascal
is a crap language I mean you you can
try and argue that with me the only
people who ever argue that with me are
people who use object Pascal I always
point out but object Pascal is not
Pascal
in the same way that Objective C is not
C and it's not small talk in the same
way that c plus is not small talk in the
same way that you pick a language it's
not whatever came before it object
Pascal is not Pascal it's a pascal-based
language it fixes most of the problems
not all of them but most of them
but this is it people held this up as an
ideal and here is one of the original
books and yeah right in there that stuff
on the right is exactly what I just
showed you in Python a moment ago it's
just like oh my God it's because Pascal
has weak abstraction mechanisms
yeah there I said it it's bad for
programming it lacks the basic tools for
data abstraction it lacks the ability to
factor out things appropriately let's
look at the kind of factions people do
so here is this structure
what are we going to do with it we're
going to refactor it okay what's the
advice on refactoring refractions about
small changes
everything works always it's about
stable intermediate forms it's like
walking okay with walking the definition
of of walking versus running is that
walking means you maintain at least one
point of contact with the ground
at any point at any point in time it's
always there it's like one two one two
running is zero one zero one maybe
that's why developers like running
okay but the problem is it's a less
stable configuration if you make a
mistake you fall it hurts a lot more
okay you may move faster but you crash
faster as well you're more likely to
crash the idea of refactoring
refactoring is walking
it's gradual change
to support us we value tests we value
automation we value another pair of eyes
these are all ways of ensuring that we
don't trip up that every step is
confidently placed this when we talk
about stable intermediate forms it's the
idea of the intermediate form between
here and there each step is stable I can
stop there and won't fall over that's
the idea if you're in a sequence of
refactoring
and that's the point is refactoring is a
plural if you're in a sequence of them
you get interrupted that's fine it all
still works that's the idea it's not
like okay this is going to be a work of
art for the next two hours I'm just
going to put on the loudest rock on
repeat on my headphones and nobody
better interrupt me because otherwise
the whole thing falls apart I can't hold
it in my head for longer than that
refactoring is like interrupting me at
any point I won't thank you for it but I
will recover from it
so we put some tests in
so here's some tests I've written in
Python without a python testing
framework it's based on a property-based
testing style
um it just basically checks that what
we've got is Meaningful stuff I'm not
expecting you to to read this but these
are the tests that I use when messing
about with this code or these are the
refactored tests I use when messing
about this code and so we can take this
and
what are we going to do well what most
people look at first
is they see the recurrence they see a
repetition
they see that there is a grouping here
while if if while if if if while if if
if and then one more while for luck
there's always one left over
so in other words what we can factor out
we can recognize that it's not just
while if if
it's that there is another structure
here
the numeric structure it's a 10
something nine something five something
four something
1900 500 400 okay 90 or 190 50 40 10 9 5
4. there's a recurrence there we fit
we've seen the repetition we're cool
we're going to extract it
not so fast
extract method is one of the most
popular techniques but actually I'm
going to say not always but in most
cases it's premature don't extract the
method yet
the problem here is that you haven't
looked enough at the control flow people
don't think about control flow enough
people think oh control flow that's the
thing you used to worry about in the 70s
and 80s no it's the basic ingredient of
a lot of software particularly in
imperative languages control flow
matters you need to this is a control
flow problem you need to understand why
we have while if if and are there any
other Transformations you can make well
one of the most simple Transformations
is to recognize that in the limit an if
is like a while
and if there's a thing that executes
zero or once a while is the thing that
execute zero once or many
in the limit
some ifs can be replaced with a while
not all don't don't get please don't go
into work and do that tomorrow just that
would be really bad things will break
but sometimes in the edge case I can
happily replace
all of the ifs with the Wiles this is a
degenerate case in this case it works
perfectly
that's interesting because what that
actually means is that our unit of
repetition is this it's not the block of
ten nine five four it's a single loop
with two modifications what we need to
do is to extract the data structure this
problem is not a control flow problem as
it was first presented to us the control
flow was like a kind of a squid ink it
kind of it clouded our judgment you need
to look through it and go oh this is a
data structure problem the control flow
is trivial
actually it's the data model that's
important here
is this a new advice no it isn't
um in the mythical man month and the
second edition actually I think it was
in even in the first no it was in the
first edition so in other words this is
something that Fred Brooks wrote in this
in the 70s
Under The Heading of representation is
the essence of programming he said
sometimes the Strategic breakthrough
will be a new algorithm
much more often strategic breakthrough
will come from redoing the
representation of the data or tables
this is where the heart of the program
is this is the soul of your code it's
the data structure it's not the control
flow and yet we because we don't
understand the control flow we don't see
the hidden data structures we end up
with a very imperative style of
programming John Von Neumann
in his Turing award speech are in 1977
published 78
he talked about probably this is the
longest longest uh touring award speech
title of all can programming be
liberated from the Von Neumann style a
functional style and its algebra of
programs
it's also one of the most technical
presentations ever for a touring award
speech notice he says style the word
Paradigm was not yet used you had to
wait one more year before Robert Floyd
won the Turing award and introduced the
world of programming to the word
paradigm okay paradigms are programming
was his paper the following year people
were not using the word Paradigm in
software at all so there is a kind of
like a break point 1978 onwards people
start using the word Paradigm before
that it's just Style
and he makes this observation he said
conventional programming languages are
basically high level complex versions of
the Von Neumann computer
okay Von Neumann languages use variables
to imitate storage
control statements elaborate jump and
Test instructions and assignment
statements imitate fetching story and
arithmetic now is an interesting thing
I'm going to take a
I'm going to take an example to kind of
exemplify the fact that we're really bad
at understanding our own State change
lots of people kind of say oh we're
doing kind of functional stuff and then
I look at their code it's just like no
you're not you've just got a couple of
immutable objects and a bit of Link
it's kind of like it's kind of like uh
functional sprinkling but it doesn't
make it functional you've not paid
attention to what are the changes you'd
keep modifying variables and you have
incredibly imperative control flow
control flow has State you can make
control flow less stateless I'll give
you one piece of advice today remember
the ifs have an else
for some reason recently people have
I've even seen talks and blogs saying I
no longer use else's and it's just like
great when's when's your next blog I use
assembler
um
people have missed the message control
flow has State that's a really important
thing you can make your control for Less
stateless by using else technology I've
just realized The Branding let's call it
a technology and people use it anyway
that's that's by the buy okay so I'm not
expecting you to read this code although
quite frankly the size of the screen you
can probably read this
I want you to get an impression of this
code
this code is from the Gilded Rose
refactoring Carter if you've never tried
this Carter it's good fun it's a pure
refactoring card it's not about it you
do need to put some tests in but it's
not about adding new functionality the
goal of this is actually to refactor the
code and I like this because it actually
looks a lot like control flow that I see
in real code
it's very it's very evolved it's been
around for a while nobody ever sat down
to write it like this it just got added
and added and added it's it's the
process of accumulation coupled with a
process of neglect
so we can see the structure there what
I'm going to do is I'm going to get rid
of all the curly brackets
there is actually by the way as an aside
there is a strong case
for going against one of the practices
people now regard as good practice
always put curly braces around your
blocks actually I go the other way I
challenge people to make everything
single statement there are a number of
consequences of that one of which is
actually safer but that's another talk
I'll just leave that one dangling there
if you go I don't believe it Kevin just
called the open close principle crap and
he's telling us that Curly brackets
around blocks is not the way to go
if your language requires it then of
course you do it
I'm not asking that you don't compile
your code but I am saying you might be
surprised but that's another story so I
want to focus on the things that happen
here
and when I talk about the things that
happen let me highlight in white all the
places where there is State change
these are all the places where
um oh sorry
all the places where we get some kind of
modification of State yeah so these are
all places with State change I'm going
to narrow it you don't need to know what
this represents
but this looks like feature Envy item I
dot quality
we if we look here these are all the
places that that is modified and here
are all the places it is referred to
this is what is referred to as the
feature Envy smell we are constantly
repeatingly going back to this
sometimes to check it sometimes to
modify it's like we can't leave it alone
it's just oh I want to change it I want
to look at look at it again maybe it's
changing a lot I need to this
immediately tells us that our control
flow is there's something wrong here and
in the worst case this is the worst case
scenario this is the path where we so
item quality we look at it one two three
four five six seven eight times uh or
can I not count it's seven sorry plus
one
um so it's seven times we look at it
and we modify it in four places
it's like we can't leave it alone
it's bizarre it's just like what what
have we done that keeps causing us to
reassign and recheck and reassign and
recheck
so here's the refracted version now one
of the things I like about the
Guild of Rose Carter is that I find a
lot of people they do two things with
the one or two things that take them in
the wrong direction
when they do this one of them
is they look at this and they say
I am going to extract method everywhere
premature extract method actually
prevents you from seeing the commonality
you need to sometimes you need to put
it's like tidying a room you need to put
everything in one place to see what's
going on then you need to reclassify it
don't pull it out based on your initial
conceptions you will prevent yourself
seeing what's wrong the other thing that
people do is try and add an object model
which would be fine if it were an
object-oriented problem it's not an
object or any problem though
so anybody doing this with classes just
creates more complexity
first of all take it at the level at
which it's presented it's a control flow
problem how do I improve the control
flow because we seem to be modifying and
looking at everything okay
this if we flip the control flow if we
take an approach to control flow where
we understand that what we are doing is
effectively setting up some kind of
Pipeline and selection mechanism then
what you end up with so let's re re um
resize this
drop the curlies
the ones in white that's the only place
State change happens now
there's no other state change here the
only other value being assigned quality
adjustment that's not an assignment
that's an initialization
okay in other words that value is an
assigned once very it's basically a
constant
there is only one place where State
change happens and there is only one
place where we look at item quality and
this is just the control flow
refactoring
take take the code on the terms it
presents you can I clean it up at that
level and then if you start saying well
that's really funny I've got a selection
and then I've got a response to it
at this point it's just like actually
it's a table lookup problem it's a data
driven problem it's a declarative
problem it's a table problem
but now I have lambdas hanging off this
is what I do in this case I classify so
I basically end up with
here are the tables this is how to find
the right entry in the table tables find
the thing do the thing tables find the
thing do the thing that's it it's a
table driven problem it's not an object
or into problem it's not even a control
flow problem
but it was presented as a control flow
problem now when I look at this
there's the state change that we had
before and there is the only point where
we actually modify the quality but now
it's a lookup problem very very
different in that sense
and it's a reminder that this is what
abstraction is about it's not to be
vague
it is to create a new semantic level in
which we can be absolutely precise if we
go back to just a simple
structure here so
this is not a lot of code
in all the examples I show they're not a
lot of codes oh yeah but we have a big
system how do you think you've got a big
system
you've got a big system because All the
Small Things became big
it turns out that you know I work with a
team a number of years ago we had this
kind of like method that was about eight
lines long
and I said what does this do and
everybody went ah
it was just this tangle of logic and
flags
so we worked on it
it came out as one line
basically it was return a does not equal
B
it turns out you can make that quite
complicated if you really try and put
your mind to it
and that was the important point the
guys then said
yeah but Kevin you've only saved us
seven lines and I said no
think about it another way I've reduced
this by a factor of eight
the funny thing is I just made an
estimate of their code base
that was was compatible with that their
code base was about a million lines long
after working with them for a few weeks
I kind of got the feeling that it should
be about 10 times smaller I said you've
done it a million lines what other teams
would do in a hundred thousand
and that's because of the little habits
if you make everything 10 times long or
eight times longer or five times longer
than it should be that's how you create
big systems so yes the little stuff
matters sweat it it's important because
that's how you if you don't pay
attention to that that's how your
systems get big and complicated now you
might say this is not the most
complicated control flow but we should
get a heads up here this is we're
looking at this and it's like suddenly
with an integer driven
counting through a list
if you are working in a language that
was invented after 1980 you have to
think you're doing something wrong
okay if I am using an integer to count
through there's something wrong and what
am I actually doing well initially it's
yeah I get a list I've got a list of
words then I sort it that's good that's
nice and high level and then I do all of
this control flow what's going on this
is a very stateful piece of control flow
so let me extract method
okay this is the block that's out of
Step
high level
take a copy of what we've got the list
of words high level saw the next level
down the mechanics of eliminating
adjacent duplicates
so therefore we do an extract rather we
remove duplicates
now this is C Sharp I can use extension
Methods at this point do a rename
because you're not really removing juice
because you're removing adjacent
duplicates you're assuming that they are
sorted so
our work here is done well not quite
because we've still we've got a new
method it's a bit tidier it's well named
but we still have all of that code
take a step back and you think
if you see Sharp you think oh I know
link that's nice for you
I tend to find that pure link
expressions in many cases are just ways
of repeating the same word Lots word
word word word if you get that level of
repetition in your um link expression
try switching it to rawlink
much better
this is what so this looks really good
notice how different this is to the
original control flow how fundamentally
different I've reframed it I've switched
Paradigm what I'm looking at here is
list of words order by the word and then
make it unique
now there's an interesting thing a lot
of C sharpers
use Link a lot
in fact they use it too much because
they don't know about data structures
I've seen some astonishing pieces of
link if you're using link probably I'm
going to say half of what you need to do
is there's probably already a method for
it
don't you don't complicate things with
additional link Expressions but more
importantly you may find there's an
additional structure
the problem with sitting in front the
solution was sitting in front of us all
of the time
oh you want to you want a list of words
that is unique and sorted
that's a data structure problem that's
not a processing problem okay that's not
a data flow problem it's not a control
flow problem
turns out that the representation is
actually the thing which leads us to
another word that people often forget
when they talk about process Improvement
they talk about Kaizen they don't talk
about Kaku
kaikaku means radical change it's also
supposed to be right we're going to
change something radical here now people
normally use this as the ways of working
but here I'm saying actually Your Design
may change radically it may look
completely different to what you had
before
so I kind of close with
another example from 97 program 97
things every program should know uh
piece by Burke Hoffner I love this piece
because I mean first of all the title is
great uh it's also good advice on its
own you know if you never do anything
else this is the yeah put the mouse down
and step away from the keyboard
yes you're stuck at the level you're
trying to solve a problem at the level
you found it you've got to take a break
you know you're stuck you clearly tried
your best but doing more of that's not
going to help you need to change your
mind literally you need to change your
mood get up go for a walk if you've been
standing sit down if you've been
drinking coffee drink herbal tea if
you've been drinking herbal tea drink
coffee if you've been listening to loud
Rock listen to something ambient or
nothing if you've been listening to
ambient or nothing put on loud rock you
need to change because whatever it is
that you are doing is not causing you to
think in the way that it's going to
solve the problem you've exhausted that
level and he shows this example
which is parsing a string that shows
time in 12 hour in 12 hour format now
what is interesting about this is that
so this Java code is kind of like
chiseling away
but not in a good Angelic sense
chiseling away at a piece of go this is
what it looked like after he refactored
it
God only knows what it was like
beforehand
and notice there's a there's a there's a
there's a dot dot dot in here
um is that working today no that is not
working oh no so that is working this is
the thing I want yeah there we go there
we go notice there is a dot dot dot
there
there's a lot of this and this is a
brutal and imperative way of trying to
solve the problem
can I pass this bit bang no okay it's
not a number okay return it's not a
valid time string and then oh wow this
is as procedural as it gets so anyway
he stepped away from the keyboard
put the mouse down
went home next day he says wait a minute
this is a declarative problem
why am I doing all this control flow
this is a declarative problem
now sometimes people joke you know hey I
had a problem and I solved it with
regular Expressions now I have two
problems or Star problems
but actually in this case what's great
is that I can show somebody who doesn't
know how to read regular expressions and
I can read it literally from left to
right and explain oh yeah you take a
zero followed by one to nine or a one
followed by zero to two then a colon
then the next group is zero to five
followed by it literally reads from left
to right
this is a nightmare by comparison it
doesn't matter if you if you know Java
this is a mess if you don't know reg X's
this is easy that's the point the
problem was a different shape it wasn't
a gradual refactoring so this tells us
this gives us a nice piece of advice
which we'll close on
advice from Isabella Beaton who is a
figure in Victorian England sadly died
by the time she was 30 but she was known
for writing a periodical and column
collected together as a the book of
household management and you might think
well I'm not running a Victorian
household
hey you're working on a code base that's
like a Victorian household
and but she gave us advice she
anticipated refactoring she gave us the
advice for refactoring software
engineering advice from the 19th century
there is no work like early work
clear as you go muddle makes more muddle
not to wash plates and dishes soon after
using makes more work this is all the
advice this is everything you need to
know if we look at that as a cleaner
this is this is to avoid neglect but
more importantly this is a proactive
design approach
the observation from herb Simon complex
system will evolve more rapidly from
systems simple systems much more radical
if there are stable intermediate forms
than if there are not
avoid the big Bank changes except when
they are needed the idea is
progressively always be improving
progressively be the idea is that think
of your design and development process
as a search
for design
is not a conclusion it's a work in
progress you are constantly searching
for it and maybe there's something
better Over the Horizon but you Embrace
that as a possibility
if we are writing code let's take the
advice of the great authors of the 20th
century
there's only the only kind of writing is
rewriting
thank you very much
[Applause]